I know what the plot of a possible
Stargate movie will be
this is quite exciting welcome to
Snapchat your Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
so before I tell you what I've been told
I'm just going to give you a little bit
of background
so about six months ago Amazon and MGM
put out a call to lots of production
companies saying come and Pitch your
ideas for a new Stargate franchise we
now know that penguin and Parker was
successful in that pitch and that they
are pushing forwards with potentially
developing a new Stargate series if they
can get through the negotiation process
with Amazon but we also know that a few
other companies also pitched and one of
those companies was bad robot now I know
what you're going to say we don't want
JJ Abrams in charge of Stargate but
that's not what this video is going to
be about I'm not discussing that I'm
just going to tell you what they pitched
so first of all I should say that around
October time they actually pitched for
the first time and that that pitch
didn't go very well apparently
Executives were let's say underwhelmed
but that sometime around late November
early December they pitched again and
one of the sources that I speak to has
been able to see their pitch bundle now
this pitch bundle is a pack that they
put together that had a summary of the
story plot now it doesn't have all of
the details apparently when they then go
into the pitch meeting they add a little
meet to these bones but this is a basic
plot summary that explains exactly what
the story and the movie would look like
and I'm going to tell you exactly what
those plot summaries were and if you
don't want to know because I should say
that this is still a possibility this
could still be made into the beginning
of the franchise this could still be
made into a Stargate movie so there will
be spoilers ahead if you don't want to
know turn off the video now
for those of you that are still left
here we go so as normal this film is
split into three acts in Act One a
civilian research team is working on an
alien world working with locals we will
see some of this work and spend time on
the alien world slowly realizing that
the alien population is actually keeping
something from the team
the team discovers an underground
complex and begins to explore this is
the first time the research team sees
hieroglyphs and other Egyptian style
architecture a Jaffa suddenly appears
and kills the team back at the SGC we
see footage from body cams of the
research team of the attack against them
and they order an SG team to go and
investigate they believe that this could
possibly be a lone Jaffa that team goes
in but is also then killed by a far
superior and larger Jaffa Force than
they expected that is the end of act one
in act two back at the SGC they
discussed different possibilities there
is a peace treaty with the free Jaffa
Nation the possibility of a goal award
is discussed an enemy that has not been
seen for well over a decade they decide
to send Jack O'Neill with a team to
investigate they ordered to hold the
gate Recon the situation and wait for
reinforcements as a BC 306 is being
dispatched
almost immediately Jack O'Neill General
Jack O'Neill
um I'm assuming they're sending him
because he's actually got experience
fighting gold but anyway we'll go into
that later
almost immediately O'Neill and his team
is attacked when they return to the
world through us and they are separated
from the gate taking serious casualties
O'Neill and the surviving members of the
team go into hiding and come across some
people living just outside the town that
the research team has been working with
him these locals tell them that a gold
world has been hiding on their world for
years to go award they call RA O'Neill
and the rest of the team make contact
with the BC 306 who informs them that
they have detected two enemy vessels in
orbit O'Neill set up a plan to begin an
attack on the surface at the same time
the BC 306 engages the enemy vessels
part of this plan requires only up to
five ra and know where he is so he
cannot Escape
O'Neill with the help of the locals he
has Allied himself with sneaks into the
complex and fights ra who is using
children as a human shield only almost
sacrifice himself to protect these
children while signaling the attack to
begin and the location of RA during this
attack O'Neill is killed
the attack on the surface is led by the
remaining Sgt teams and they take losses
immediately but Jaffa from the free
Jaffa Nation are then being down to the
surface from the BC 306 as that comes to
their aid the ground attack eventually
Corners ra who tries to escape but is
killed that is generally the plot it
seems to end in act 3 with basically a
very aggressive assault on the surface
and in space we're going to get to see a
pretty big space battle now in this
summary the actual
um spelling of Jack O'Neill is spelled
with one L now why is that important
because as part of this pitch meeting
Bad Robot have insisted that their plan
would have Kurt Russell playing Jack
O'Neal and not Richard Dean Anderson so
guys that is the general summary plot of
the new Stargate movie now in my next
video I'm going to tell you exactly what
I think about this general plot idea now
I would love you guys to get to the
comments though before you watch that
video and tell me exactly what you think
and then on Saturday morning as part of
my gatewatch series over on Sidetrack
sides please there's a link in the
description you can go and subscribe
there now I will go through a lot of
those comments and I will share with you
guys and have that discussion with you
guys about the comments that I get so
guys get in the comments now tell me
what you think about this idea for a
storyline is this bringing back raw
something that you think is a good idea
they're going to have to be very clever
with the way they write it at the end of
the day because we saw our take a
nuclear weapon to the face
how do you feel about Kurt Russell
returning now I don't have a major
problem with this because at the end of
the day he is Colonel O'Neill just like
Richard Dean Anderson is Colonel slash
General O'Neill
so as long as it isn't a different actor
a third actor I don't really have a
problem
but do you think this is a black door
hard reboot do you think that this is
actually a continuation of the story or
basically just a sequel to the original
Stargate movie I'd love to know exactly
what you think was if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us out
and if you want to support the channel
even further please consider hitting the
join Button as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next time in the next
video
foreign
[Music]